It seems to me that the way that you
fortify your faith in being and in life
and your own existence isn't to try to
convince yourself of the existence of a
transcendent power that you could
believe in the same way that you believe
in a set of empirical facts.
I don't.
I don't think that's the right approach.
I think it's a weak approach.
Actually.
I don't.
I don't think that the cognitive
technology that I don't think that's the
right cognitive technology for that set
of problems.
You know,
that's more a technology that you use if
you were trying to solve a scientific
problem.
It's more like it's more something that
needs to be embedded in action rather
than in stateable belief and the way
that you fortify your faith in life is
to assume the best,
something like that,
and then to act courageously in
relationship to that and,
and that's,
that's tantamount to expressing your
faith in the highest possible good.
It's tantamount to expressing your faith
in God and it's not a matter of stating,
well,
I believe in the existence of a
transcendent that daddy,
because in some sense,
who cares?
Who cares what you believe.
I mean you might and all that,
but,
but that's not the issue.
That's not the issue.
The issue it seems to me is how you act,
and I was thinking about this intensely
when I was thinking about Nietzsche and
Dostoevsky because of course you know
that nature was the philosopher who
announced the death of God,
right?
And who is a great,
great critic of Christianity at vicious
critic of Institutional Christianity in
the best sense,
you know,
and he announced the death of God and he
said that we'd never find enough water
to wash away the blood.
It wasn't a triumphant proclamation even
though it's often read that way and
don't need shoes.
Conclusion from that,
from the death of God,
the fact that our ethical systems,
we're going to collapse.
When the foundation was pulled out from
underneath him,
he believed that human beings would have
to find their own values to create their
own values.
And there's a problem with that because
it doesn't seem that this is something
Carl young was very thorough and
investigating,
it doesn't really look like people are
capable of creating their own values
because you're not really capable of
molding yourself just any old way.
You want to be like you have a nature
that you have to contend with and so it
isn't a matter of creating our own
values because we don't have that
capacity.
It might be a matter of rediscovering
those values,
which is what young was attempting to do
now.
And,
and,
and so I think nature was actually
profoundly wrong in that,
in that recommendation.
I think he was psychologically wrong.
Now you know,
there was the Husky wrote in many ways
in parallel to Nisha and was a great
influence on nature.
Their,
their lives parallel each other.
To a degree that's somewhat miraculous
in some senses.
It's quite uncanny.
Dostoevsky was obviously a literary
figure,
whether whereas nature was a
philosopher,
a literary philosopher,
but still have last for Dostoevsky,
wrestled with exactly the same problems
that,
that nature wrestled with.
And,
but he did it in a different way.
He didn't literary manner and he has
this great book,
the brothers Karamazov and in that book
there's a hero of the book is really Lee
Osha Who's a monastic novitiate,
a very good guy,
kinda not an intellect,
not an intellect,
but a person of great character,
but he has a brother.
I have an older brother who's a great
intellect and and a very handsome
soldier and a brave man and like
Dostoyevsky's villains.
Ivan isn't exactly a villain,
but that's close enough.
Ivan or Dostoevsky makes his villains
extraordinarily powerful.
So if Dostoevsky's trying to work out an
argument,
he,
he clothes the argument in the,
in the flesh of one of his characters
and if it's an argument he doesn't agree
with,
then he makes that character as strong
as he possibly can,
as strong and as attractive and
intelligent as he possibly can.
And then he let some just have outer.
And so Ivan is constantly attacking Lee
Osha and from every direction trying to
knock him off his perch of faith,
let's say.
And they'll Osha,
Ellie,
Osha can't address a single one of
Ivan's criticisms and,
and he doesn't have the intellect for
it.
And,
and,
and Ivan has a devastating intellect.
It's devastating to him himself as well.
What happens in the brothers Karamazov
essentially is the lel.
Osha continues to act out his commitment
to the good,
let's say.
And in that manner,
he is triumphant.
It doesn't matter that he loses the
arguments because the arguments aren't
exactly the point.
The arguments in some sense are aside
issue because the issue is,
and this is the existential issue,
the issue is not what you believe as if
it's a set of facts,
but how you conduct yourself in the
world.